Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. February 5, 1921 was far from a typical Saturday afternoon in the valley town of Abbottoliri, Wales.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目说明。本期节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。1921年2月5日，对威尔士阿伯泰勒里（Abbottoliri）山谷小镇来说，绝不是一个平常的星期六下午。
Locals had rallied together to undertake a desperate search. Crescent residences along the main street were checked, as were the narrow alleyways between them. Men and their sons ventured off into the surrounding hills, while others trekked the lengths of the railway tracks and the nearby Ebor River. Their efforts were in vain. But they didn't give up. As the dull skies gave way to night, people were still searching.
当地人联合起来展开了一场绝望的搜寻。主街沿线的住宅受到了检查，它们之间的狭窄小巷也是如此。男人和他们的儿子们冒险进入周围的山丘，而其他人则沿着铁路线和附近的埃博尔河（Ebor River）上下搜寻。他们的努力是徒劳的。但他们并没有放弃。随着阴沉的天空逐渐变黑，人们仍在搜寻。
They were joined by the town crier, who paraded up and down the main street, shouting the name of the eight-year-old girl who had vanished from town that morning. Freed up, Bernel. Freed up, Bernel. Hours earlier, Freed up, Bernel had been skipping down Somerset Street into Abbottoliri's bustling town centre. The side of little Freed up, in her black buttoned boots, red cap and brown coat, all by herself, didn't raise any eyebrows.
镇上的传令官加入了他们的行列，他在主街上游行，大声喊着那个那天早上在镇上失踪的八岁女孩的名字。弗里达·伯内尔（Freed up, Bernel）。弗里达·伯内尔。几小时前，弗里达·伯内尔还蹦蹦跳跳地顺着萨默塞特街（Somerset Street）走入阿伯泰勒里繁华的市中心。小弗里达穿着黑色纽扣靴、戴着红帽子、穿着棕色大衣，独自一人，并没有引起任何人的注意。
The coal mining town she called home was small, and the locals trusted each other. Freed up was running an errand for her father, who was in need of some feed and poultry grit for the chickens they owned. He had promised his daughter a penny as a reward for buying the supplies on his behalf. At around 9am, the bell at the top of the front door of Mortimer's store jingled as Freed up entered. The shop specialised in livestock supplies, and while they had the chicken feed Freed up requested, there weren't any sacks of grit, only loose grit.
她称之为家的这个煤矿小镇很小，当地人彼此信任。弗里达正在为父亲跑腿，父亲需要一些他们养的鸡吃的饲料和家禽砂砾。他曾承诺女儿，如果她代为买回这些物资，就奖励她一分钱。大约上午9点，当弗里达走进莫蒂默（Mortimer's）商店时，前门顶部的铃铛叮当作响。这家商店专门经营牲畜用品，虽然他们有弗里达要求的鸡饲料，但没有任何袋装砂砾，只有散装砂砾。
Freed up said she would go home to ask her father if that would suffice, and if so, she would come back. But she never returned. By late afternoon, Abbottoliri's locals were assisting police and the Bernel family in trying to locate Freed up. Somehow, during her journey home from Mortimer's store, she had vanished without a trace. The following morning, a local coal worker finished his shift in the mines and began the walk back to his home.
弗里达说她要回家问问父亲这样是否可以，如果可以，她会再回来。但她再也没有回来。到傍晚时分，阿伯泰勒里的当地人正协助警察和伯内尔一家寻找弗里达。不知何故，在她从莫蒂默商店回家的路上，她消失得无影无踪。第二天早上，当地的一名煤矿工人在矿上结束了夜班，开始步行回家。
As he approached Abbottoliri's town centre, he headed down a narrow side alley, where he stumbled across a Hessian sack discarded in the mud. It clearly held something. The coal worker examined the sack closely. Inside was the body of 8-year-old Freed up Bernel. Her remains had been dumped just 90 metres from her house. Freed up had sustained a violent blow to the head, but it was the cord still wrapped around her neck that had caused her death.
当他走近阿伯泰勒里市中心时，他走进了一条狭窄的小巷，在那里他无意中发现了泥地里丢弃的一个麻袋。里面显然装着东西。煤矿工人仔细检查了这个麻袋。里面是8岁女孩弗里达·伯内尔的尸体。她的遗体被抛弃在距离她家仅90米的地方。弗里达头部遭受了猛烈的撞击，但真正导致她死亡的是缠在她脖子上的绳索。
A piece of cloth was stuffed inside her mouth, and her wrists and ankles were tied behind her back with rope. Her attacker had also attempted to rape her. The shocking murder rattled the typically carefree townsfolk. Freed's funeral was held on the street outside her home to facilitate the large crowds of mourners that wished to attend. They circled around her small coffin, their sense of loss tinged with fear as they wondered who among them would carry out such a violent and disturbing crime.
她嘴里塞着一块布，手腕和脚踝用绳子反绑在身后。她的袭击者还试图强奸她。这起令人震惊的谋杀案震惊了平时无忧无虑的镇民。弗里达的葬礼在她家门外的街道上举行，以便容纳希望参加的大批哀悼者。他们围在她的小棺材周围，失落感中夹杂着恐惧，他们想知道他们当中究竟是谁犯下了如此暴力和令人不安的罪行。
In a desperate bid to identify Freed's killer, locals carried out a seance. In the 1920s, it was widely believed that such acts allowed communication with spirits who might be able to provide crucial information. According to one participant, the seance succeeded, with the spirits offering a description of Freed's murderer. This description just so happened to match that of a man seen loitering near the alley shortly before her body was found there. He was an outsider and not known to the townspeople.
为了极力找出弗里达的凶手，当地人举行了一场降神会。在20世纪20年代，人们普遍认为这种行为可以与可能提供关键信息的灵魂进行交流。据一位参与者称，降神会成功了，灵魂们对外貌进行了描述，这与弗里达的谋杀犯相符。这个描述恰好与在她尸体被发现前不久被看到在小巷附近徘徊的一个男子的外貌相吻合。他是个外地人，镇民们都不认识他。
From 30 to 40 years of age, approximately 5 feet 6 inches tall, with dark hair and a heavy mustache. He was wearing dark breeches, a lounge coat and carrying a stick. The information obtained via the seance was taken seriously at the time, but local authorities sought further evidence. This type of crime was unheard of in arbitrary and was beyond their expertise, so they requested assistance from London's experienced and well-equipped Scotland Yard Police Force. Two detectives soon arrived in town to carry out an investigation.
年龄在30到40岁之间，身高约5英尺6英寸，留着深色头发和浓密的胡须。他穿着深色马裤、休闲西装外套，手里拿着一根棍子。通过降神会获得的信息在当时受到了重视，但地方当局寻求更多的证据。这种类型的犯罪在阿伯泰勒里闻所未闻，超出了他们的专业范围，因此他们请求伦敦经验丰富且装备精良的苏格兰场警察部队协助。两名侦探不久便抵达镇上开展调查。
It was determined that Freedah was murdered between 9.30am and 1pm on the day she went missing. Her body was found in close proximity to a shed used by Mortimer's store, which contained stock too large to fit on the shop floor. Multiple witnesses said that shortly after Freedah left Mortimer's, they heard screams coming from the direction of the storage shed, but assumed it was just children playing. A resident who lived near the building heard what she described as a muffled, funny-sounding argument between 9.20 and 9.30am.
经确定，弗里达是在她失踪当天的上午9点30分至下午1点之间被谋杀的。她的尸体被发现在靠近莫蒂默商店的一个棚屋附近，该棚屋里存放着太大而无法放入店面的存货。多名目击者称，在弗里达离开莫蒂默后不久，他们听到储藏室方向传来尖叫声，但以为只是小孩子在玩耍。一名住在该建筑附近的居民听到她形容为在9点20分到9点30分之间听起来很滑稽的、闷声闷气的争吵。
She thought it was her son in the backyard hurting one of their chickens, but when she headed outside to check, she found her son playing in a nearby lane. On the floor of the Mortimer's shed were loose pieces of corn chaff, matching shards recovered from Freedah's skin and the sack she was found in. A small handkerchief that Freedah was carrying the day she was attacked was also discovered in the shed, as was an axe. It was hidden under a sack, and while the blade itself was clean, the handle was covered in wet blood.
她以为是自己的儿子在后院弄伤了他们的鸡，但当她走出去查看时，发现她的儿子正在附近的巷子里玩耍。莫蒂默棚屋的地上有碎玉米壳，这与从弗里达皮肤上以及发现她的麻袋中回收的碎片相吻合。弗里达遭受袭击当天随身携带的一块小手帕也在棚屋里被发现，一把斧头也是如此。它藏在一个麻袋下面，虽然斧刃本身很干净，但斧柄上沾满了湿血。
The shed was 275m from Mortimer's store, which was owned and operated by its namesake, a local man named Herbert Mortimer. Herbert had a strong alibi for the day of Freedah's murder, with multiple witnesses confirming his whereabouts at the time she was attacked. As for his storage shed, Herbert revealed that it was kept locked at all times, and that there were only two keys that granted access. Herbert carried one. The other was held by one of his employees, 15-year-old Harold Jones.
该棚屋距离莫蒂默商店275米，该商店由同名的当地人赫伯特·莫蒂默（Herbert Mortimer）拥有和经营。赫伯特对弗里达被谋杀那天有强有力不在场证明，多名目击者证实了她在遭受袭击时的行踪。至于他的储藏室，赫伯特透露，它一直处于锁闭状态，只有两把钥匙可以进入。赫伯特随身携带一把。另一把由他的一个员工、15岁的哈罗德·琼斯（Harold Jones）保管。
Harold was at the front counter when Freedah visited Mortimer's on February 5. She arrived shortly after 9am, and only spent around two minutes in the store. Harold didn't notice which direction she headed in upon exiting the shop. Herbert Mortimer vouched for his young staff member, telling detectives that Harold Jones was at the store nearly all morning. Herbert's wife supported this assertion. She had been in their apartment above the shop, and could hear Harold banging his foot against the wood paneling of the counter, something he did constantly as he walked.
2月5日弗里达光顾莫蒂默时，哈罗德正在前台。她刚过9点到达，在店里只呆了大约两分钟。哈罗德没有注意到她出店后朝哪个方向走去。赫伯特·莫蒂默为他的年轻员工作担保，告诉侦探哈罗德·琼斯几乎整个上午都在店里。赫伯特的妻子证实了这一说法。她一直在楼上的公寓里，能听到哈罗德用脚踢柜台的木镶板，这是他走路时经常做的一个动作。
According to Herbert, Harold only left once for a short period at 10am, almost an hour after Freedah Bernal had stopped by. He'd been tasked with retrieving some stock from the shed, but the teenager didn't go alone. Herbert's 10-year-old son Francis joined him. The pair made the short walk together, collected a sack of potatoes from the shed, and delivered them to a nearby address before returning to the store. Later that day, when word spread that Freedah Bernal was missing, Harold slid his hand into
据赫伯特说，哈罗德在上午10点左右只离开了一小会儿，几乎是在弗里达·伯内尔离开一小时后。他被派去从棚屋取回一些存货，但这个少年并不是一个人去的。赫伯特10岁的儿子弗朗西斯（Francis）加入了他的行列。两人一起短距离步行，从棚屋里取出一袋土豆，将它们送到附近的地址，然后返回店里。那天晚些时候，当弗里达·伯内尔失踪的消息传开时，哈罗德把手伸进
his pocket, only to realise that he didn't have the key to the shed on him. Then dawned that he must have left it in the shed's door after running the errand with Francis Mortimer hours earlier. Harold kept news of the misplaced key to himself, avoiding the fuss that would arise if his employer knew of his mistake. Later on, while helping look for Freedah, Harold went back to the shed with Francis Mortimer and another local team, and was able to retrieve the key. He didn't notice anything suspicious around the building at the time.
他的口袋，却意识到身上没有棚屋的钥匙。随后他恍然大悟，一定是几个小时前和弗朗西斯·莫蒂默一起跑腿时把它忘在棚屋门上了。哈罗德对钥匙放错地方的消息闭口不谈，以免让雇主知道他的错误而引起大惊小怪。后来，在帮忙寻找弗里达时，哈罗德和弗朗西斯·莫蒂默以及另一个当地团队回到了棚屋，并成功找回了钥匙。当时他没有注意到大楼周围有什么可疑之处。
Harold's story of leaving the key in the shed door opened the investigation up to many potential suspects. Anyone could have taken Freedah into the secluded building upon realising it was accessible. Yet, despite having a strong alibi, Harold Jones was eyed by Scotland Yard as a prime suspect in the case. The 15-year-old knew Freedah Bernal personally, as she was friends with his little sister, Flossie. Consequently, a level of trust existed between Harold and Freedah, which meant he could have
哈罗德把钥匙落在棚屋门上的说法，让这项调查牵扯出许多潜在的嫌疑人。任何人一旦意识到该建筑可以进入，都可能把弗里达带进这个偏僻的建筑里。然而，尽管有强有力的不在场证明，哈罗德·琼斯还是被苏格兰场视为该案的主要嫌疑人。这个15岁的男孩认识弗里达·伯内尔，因为她是他的小妹妹弗洛西（Flossie）的朋友。因此，哈罗德和弗里达之间存在一定程度的信任，这意味着他可以
easily convinced her to go to the shed. The alleyway where she was later found had been searched the night she vanished, but the sack containing her remains was not spotted at that time. Investigators suspected Harold had returned to the shed in the early hours and removed Freedah's body under the cover of darkness, before dumping it in the alley where it was discovered the following day. But none of this made sense to Abitaliri's residence. Jones' employers vouched for his whereabouts at the time Freedah was attacked.
轻而易举地劝说她去棚屋。她后来被发现的小巷在她失踪当晚就被搜查过，但当时并没有发现装着她遗体的麻袋。调查人员怀疑哈罗德在清晨返回棚屋，在夜色的掩护下转移了弗里达的尸体，然后将其扔进第二天被发现的小巷里。但这一切在阿伯泰勒里居民看来都说不通。琼斯的老板为弗里达遇袭时的行踪作了担保。
Furthermore, Harold's parents insisted that their son had been home all night. As a means of obtaining additional income, the Jones family hosted a border who, due to a lack of space, actually slept in Harold's bed alongside him. The border maintained that Harold had remained in their shared bed all night. Despite the town coming to his support, Harold Jones was arrested on suspicion of Freedah Bernal's murder and held at the Abitaliri police station to await an inquest into the eight-year-old's death. He adamantly denied any knowledge of the crime.
此外，哈罗德的父母坚称他们的儿子一整晚都在家。为了获得额外收入，琼斯一家接待了一名房客，由于空间不足，他实际上和哈罗德睡在同一张床上。房客坚称哈罗德一整晚都呆在他们共用的床上。尽管全镇都来支持他，哈罗德·琼斯仍因涉嫌谋杀弗里达·伯内尔而被捕，并被关押在阿伯泰勒里警察局，等待对这名八岁女孩死因的死因研讯。他坚决否认自己知道这起罪行。
The grief that had washed over Abitaliri following the murder was quickly replaced by outrage over the arrest of Harold, who was an exemplary young lad. Like many others in the community, he came from a coal mining family. The working-class Joneses made do with what they had and were immensely proud of their eldest son, Harold, who was intelligent and well-read. He was very much loved by his parents, Philip and Eleanor, and neither he nor anyone in his family had any previous run-ins with the law. Harold was an inquisitive youth and had done very well at school, with his former principal
谋杀案后笼罩阿伯泰勒里的悲痛，很快就被对逮捕哈罗德的愤怒所取代，他是一个堪称楷模的年轻小伙。和社区里的许多人一样，他来自一个煤矿工人家庭。工人阶级的琼斯一家有什么就用什么，并为他们聪明好学的大儿子哈罗德感到无比自豪。他的父母菲利普（Philip）和埃莉诺（Eleanor）非常疼爱他，他和他的家人以前都没有过违法记录。哈罗德是一个充满好奇心的青年，在学校表现非常好，他的前校长
describing him as a model student. He loved to play the organ and practiced regularly at home. Harold left school at age 14, which was common at the time. He avoided taking up work in the physically demanding and dangerous coal mines by securing a job as a shop boy for mortemers. To mark his new employment, Harold had a photo taken of himself standing outside the store. It showed the slight teen immaculately dressed in a suit, complete with pocket watch and cap.
形容他是一个模范学生。他喜欢弹风琴，经常在家练习。哈罗德14岁时辍学，这在当时很常见。他通过保住一份为莫蒂默当店员的工作，避免了从事体力要求高且危险的煤矿工作。为了纪念他的新工作，哈罗德拍了一张自己站在店外面的照片。照片显示这个瘦削的少年衣着无可挑剔，穿着西装，配有怀表和帽子。
Not one to have his photo taken often, Harold stood awkwardly before the camera, which captured his blank expression. Herbert Mortimer said Harold was an obedient and trustworthy employee, which was why he gave him a key to his storage shed. Harold took great pride in his appearance, wearing a suit and clean white apron to work every day, and his friendly nature ensured he was well liked by customers. Outside of work, the popular Harold was never short of friends and had started dating a girl just prior to his arrest.
哈罗德不常拍照，他在镜头前显得很不自然，脸上带着茫然的表情。赫伯特·莫蒂默说，哈罗德是一个听话且值得信赖的员工，这就是为什么他给了他一把储藏室的钥匙。哈罗德对自己的外表感到非常自豪，每天上班都穿着西装和干净的白色围裙，他友善的性格确保了他深受顾客喜爱。工作之余，受欢迎的哈罗德从不缺朋友，并在被捕前不久开始和一个女孩约会。
Still, the investigators from Scotland Yard were certain they had Frida's killer in custody. Local police supported their decision, much to the fury of the public. They knew an outsider was to blame. A coroner's inquest into the death of Frida Bernal formally began a month after she was found. Harold's purpose was to determine whether Frida's death was caused by willful murder, and if so, whether Harold Jones would face a criminal trial. Due to a lack of scientific testing at the time, the evidence against Harold was largely
尽管如此，苏格兰场的调查人员确信他们已经拘留了弗里达的凶手。当地警方支持他们的决定，这引发了公众的极大愤怒。他们知道罪魁祸首是一个外地人。在弗里达·伯内尔被发现一个月后，对她死因的验尸官研讯正式开始。哈罗德的目的是确定弗里达的死是否是由蓄意谋杀引起的，如果是的话，哈罗德·琼斯是否将面临刑事审判。由于当时缺乏科学检测手段，对哈罗德不利的证据主要是
circumstantial. Harold had spent the past month in a prison cell at Aberteleiri police station. From taking the witness box, he looked nervous and had difficulty answering questions, often giving contradictory evidence. The prosecution took his anxious demeanour as a sign of guilt, and for four hours they continued to barrage him with questions. Multiple people testified in Harold's defence, including his employer, his parents, and the border who shared his bed, all in turn providing crucial alibis.
circumstantial （间接证据）。过去的一个月里，哈罗德一直被关押在阿伯泰勒里警察局的牢房里。当他走上证人席时，他显得很紧张，回答问题有困难，经常给出矛盾的证据。控方将他焦虑的举止视为有罪的信号，连续四个小时对其实施连珠炮似的发问。多人为哈罗德作无罪辩证，包括他的老板、他的父母以及和他共用一张床的房客，他们依次提供了至关重要的不在场证明。
Supporting his innocence were the reported sightings of a stick-wielding stranger with a mustache spotted on the corner of the alley where Frida was later found. This was the same man allegedly described by spirits during a seance that townsfolk held after the discovery of Frida's body. The same spirits had also apparently provided the killer's name, which was written on a piece of paper, folded, and given to the coroner for his eyes only. The jury at the centre of the inquest were left uncertain by the varying accounts and returned an open finding.
支持他无罪的是据报道在弗里达后来被发现的小巷拐角处看到的一名手持木棍、留着胡子的陌生人。据称这就是镇民在发现弗里达尸体后举行降神会时，由灵魂描述的那个人。据称，相同的灵魂还提供了凶手的名字，它写在一张纸上，折叠好后交给了验尸官独自过目。研讯核心的陪审团对各种各样的说法感到不确定，并给出了一个未定结论。
The coroner refused to accept this result, and the jury were made to reconsider. They returned with an amended verdict, concluding that Frida's cause of death was, willful murder by some person or persons unknown. Bale for Harold Jones was refused, and he was remanded in custody until April 5th, when he would be brought before a magistrate to determine whether he would go to trial. When asked if he had any response to the charges against him, Harold replied, I know it looks black against me, but I never done it. On April 5th, he was ordered to stand trial for Frida's murder.
验尸官拒绝接受这一结果，陪审团被迫重新考虑。他们带着修改后的裁决回来了，得出的结论是弗里达的死因是某名或某些身份不明之人的蓄意谋杀。哈罗德·琼斯的保释被拒绝，他被还押候审，直到4月5日被带到地方法官面前，以确定他是否受审。当被问及对针对他的指控有何回应时，哈罗德回答说：“我知道这对我对很不利，但我绝对没干。”4月5日，他被命令为弗里达的谋杀案接受审判。
Harold pleaded, not guilty. In the lead up to the trial, Herbert Mortimer sought to investigate some of the circumstantial evidence that had implicated his young employee. This included Frida's handkerchief, which was found on the floor of the storage shed, cited as evidence that she was killed there. According to the Manchester Guardian, Herbert discovered that if he leaned through one of the windows, he could drop a handkerchief that landed very near to where Frida's had been found.
哈罗德坚称自己无罪。在审判前夕，赫伯特·莫蒂默试图调查一些暗示他年轻员工有罪的间接证据。这包括在储藏室地板上发现的弗里达的手帕，它被引为她在那裏被杀害的证据。据《曼彻斯特卫报》报道，赫伯特发现，如果他探身穿过其中一扇窗户，他就可以扔下一块手帕，正好落在弗里达的手帕被发现的地方附近。
Although this failed to address the bloodied axe, the corn chaff, or multiple reports of a commotion from the shed after Frida left the store, Herbert still believed Harold to be innocent. Herbert also recalled that when he first bought the shed, its previous owner had told him that she was missing a key and he would need to have another spare made. This meant a third, unaccounted four key was still out there, which would grant its holder access to the shed. On June 21, 1921, the trial against Harold Jones for the murder of Frida Bernel commenced.
虽然这未能解决带血的斧头、碎玉米壳，或弗里达离开商店后多起从棚屋传来的骚动报告，但赫伯特仍然认为哈罗德是无辜的。赫伯特还回忆说，当他第一次买下这个棚屋时，前任业主曾告诉他，她少了一把钥匙，他需要另外配一把备用钥匙。这意味着第三把、下落不明的第四把钥匙仍然流落在外，这将使持有者能够进入棚屋。1921年6月21日，对哈罗德·琼斯谋杀弗里达·伯内尔的审判拉开帷幕。
Harold received glowing character references from his family, his former school headmaster, and his boss, Herbert Mortimer. Herbert stood by the alibi he had provided for Harold from the outset, maintaining that the teen was in his store at the time Frida was attacked. When Harold took the stand, he appeared calm and performed much better than at the inquest, answering questions without hesitation or contradiction. His cross-examination was rigorous and lengthy, but Harold remained composed throughout. The prosecution labelled Harold as heartless and someone with tremendous ability to control
哈罗德收到了来自他的家人、前学校校长和他的老板赫伯特·莫蒂默的极高评价。赫伯特从一开始就坚持为哈罗德提供的不在场证明，坚称弗里达遇袭时这个少年正在他的店里。当哈罗德走上证人席时，他显得很平静，表现得比在研讯时好得多，回答问题时毫不犹豫也没有矛盾。他的盘问严厉而漫长，但哈罗德自始至终保持镇定。控方给哈罗德贴上了冷酷无情以及具有非凡控制能力的标签
his emotions. The trial only lasted one day, after which the jury of seven men and five women retired for five hours. They returned with a unanimous decision. For the willful murder of Frida Bernel, 15-year-old Harold Jones was found not guilty. The town of Abitaliri rejoiced. Harold walked free from the courtroom and into the arms of his tearful parents. To celebrate, Harold and his family went for high tea at a local motel, a luxury reserved
他的情绪。审判只持续了一天，之后由七名男士和五名女士组成的陪审团退席闭门商议了五个小时。他们带着一致的决定回来了。因蓄意谋杀弗里达·伯内尔，15岁的哈罗德·琼斯被判无罪。阿伯泰勒里小镇欢欣鼓舞。哈罗德走出了法庭，投入了泪流满面的父母的怀抱。为了庆祝，哈罗德和家人去当地的一家汽车旅馆享用下午茶，这是一种只有在最特殊场合才能享有的奢侈待遇。
for only the most special of occasions. Locals accompanied him to share in the celebration. Some reports say that they presented him with a gold watch, with everyone who knew him to be innocent chipping in. Harold thanked his supporters. Despite his ordeal, which he described as horrendous, he said that he didn't hold a grudge against the town's people. He then jumped into an open-top vehicle decorated with fresh flowers and was driven through
当地人陪着他一起庆祝。据一些报道称，他们送给他一块金表，所有知道他是清白的人都出资凑了钱。哈罗德感谢了他的支持者。尽管经历了被他形容为可怕的磨难，他说他并没有对镇上的人心存怨恨。随后，他跳上一辆装饰着新鲜鲜花的敞篷车，被载着穿过
the streets of Abitaliri. Supporters lined the footpaths waving flags as Harold received a hero's welcome. They blamed the Scotland Yard detectives for implicating the teenager through circumstantial evidence, despite so many people providing evidence that he could not have committed the crime. As Harold made his way home, his neighbour, George Little, clapped him on the back and said, Well done lad, we knew you didn't do it.
阿伯泰勒里的街道。支持者们排在人行道两旁挥舞着旗帜，哈罗德受到了英雄般的欢迎。他们指责苏格兰场的侦探通过间接证据牵连这名少年，尽管有这么多的人提供了他不可能犯罪的证据。当哈罗德往家走时，他的邻居乔治·利特尔（George Little）拍了拍他的背说：“干得好，小伙子，我们知道你没干。”
On Friday July 8, 1921, 11-year-old Florence Little completed her homework, ate her dinner and did her nightly chores. At 9pm, she asked her father George if she could go outside and play for a while. With his permission, Florence met her good friend Flossie Jones outside on Darren Street, Abitaliri. As the two young girls lived just a few doors from one another, they played together often. That night, they skipped along playing hopscotch, unaware that someone was watching them. Afterwards, the pair headed to Flossie's home, but Flossie soon left to visit an aunt
1921年7月8日星期五，11岁的弗洛伦斯·利特尔（Florence Little）写完了家庭作业，吃过晚饭，并做完了每晚的家务。晚上9点，她问父亲乔治是否可以出去玩一会儿。在得到他的允许后，弗洛伦斯在阿伯泰勒里的达伦街（Darren Street）外遇到了她的好朋友弗洛西·琼斯。由于这两个年轻女孩住得只有几门之隔，她们经常一起玩。那天晚上，她们跳着格子跳房子，浑然不知有人在注视着她们。之后，两人前往弗洛西的家，但弗洛西很快就动身去拜访一位姑姑
in a neighbouring street. She bid farewell to her friend before heading out the door. Florence didn't return to her own home, instead staying at the Jones' house. She wasn't alone. Although present was Flossie's older brother, 15-year-old Harold Jones. It had been 17 days since he was acquitted for the murder of Frida Bernal to the jubilation of his town. According to differing reports, Harold either invited Florence to stay for a glass of lemonade
在一条相邻的街道上。她在出门前向朋友道别。弗洛伦斯没有回家，而是留在了琼斯家。她并不孤单。尽管在场的是弗洛西的哥哥、15岁的哈罗德·琼斯。距离他因谋杀弗里达·伯内尔而在全镇的欢呼声中被宣告无罪释放已经过去了17天。根据不同的报道，哈罗德要么邀请弗洛伦斯留下来喝杯柠檬水
or asked her to assist him in running an errand. Since Harold's trial, Florence had been cautious around him, but she ultimately accepted his offer. The rest of the Joneses were out at the time, leaving Florence alone with Harold. He shut and locked the front door. Around an hour later, Florence's mother, Elsie, arrived at the Jones' residence. She knocked on the door, and after about two minutes, Harold answered. He was shirtless and smiling.
或者请她帮忙跑腿。自哈罗德受审以来，弗洛伦斯一直对他在提防着，但她最终还是接受了他的提议。琼斯一家的其他人当时都不在家，只留下弗洛伦斯和哈罗德单独呆在一起。他关上并锁上了前门。大约一个小时后，弗洛伦斯的母亲埃尔茜（Elsie）来到了琼斯家。她敲了敲门，大约两分钟后，哈罗德开了门。他光着膀子，面带微笑。
He told Elsie that he had just been taking a bath. She asked if he had seen Florence as she hadn't returned from playing with Flossie. Harold said that she had been at the house, but left earlier via a back door with the intention of going home. Elsie looked for her daughter throughout the surrounding streets, but failed to find her. Nervous and scared, she phoned the local police, who commenced their own search at 11.15pm. Word quickly spread, and just as they had done with Frida Bernal five months earlier,
他告诉埃尔茜他刚刚洗了个澡。她问他是否见过弗洛伦斯，因为她和弗洛西玩耍后还没有回来。哈罗德说她确实来过家里，但早些时候从后门离开，打道回府了。埃尔茜在周围的街道上寻找她的女儿，却一无所获。她紧张而害怕，给当地警方打了电话，警方于晚上11点15分开始了自己的搜寻。消息迅速传开，就像五个月前搜寻弗里达·伯内尔一样，
locals gathered to look for another little girl. Coal miners who were due to start work at 5am left their warm beds to search in the freezing cold. Among the many locals looking for Florence was Harold Jones, who returned home at 3.30am. Harold climbed out of bed the following morning and ate breakfast, all the while seeming his normal self. A short while later, police officers arrived to question him in relation to Florence Little's disappearance.
当地人聚集起来寻找另一个小女孩。本应在凌晨5点开始工作的煤矿工人离开了温暖的床，在严寒中搜寻。在寻找弗洛伦斯的众多当地人中，有哈罗德·琼斯，他在凌晨3点30分回到了家。第二天早上，哈罗德起床吃早饭，一如既往地表现得很正常。不久之后，警察赶到，就弗洛伦斯·利特尔的失踪对进行盘问。
He calmly smoked a cigarette, while telling them that Florence had arrived at his doorstep the night before, but then ran off. After the interview, Harold strolled outside to visit some friends a few streets away. Given that he had just been involved in a murder trial involving a very similar incident, the police weren't convinced that Harold had nothing to do with Florence's disappearance. Officers spoke with Harold's father, Philip Jones, and advised him that they wanted to search his house. He replied,
他平静地抽着烟，同时告诉他们弗洛伦斯前一天晚上来到了他家门口，但随后跑掉了。讯问结束后，哈罗德漫步出去拜访几条街外的一些朋友。鉴于他刚刚卷入了一起涉及极其相似事件的谋杀案，警方并不相信哈罗德与弗洛伦斯的失踪无关。警官们与哈罗德的父亲菲利普·琼斯进行了交谈，并告知他他们想搜查他的房子。他回答说：
Very well, come along. A rudimentary search of the Jones' home uncovered nothing that raised suspicion. However, it looked as though the kitchen walls had been recently cleaned, with white marks streaked across them. An examination of Harold's clothes revealed seven ladies' handkerchiefs stuffed into some trouser pockets. These discoveries prompted a more thorough inspection of the home. A check under the kitchen sink revealed a bloodied pocket knife.
“好吧，进来吧。”对琼斯家进行的基础搜查没有发现任何引起怀疑的东西。然而，厨房的墙壁似乎最近刚被清洗过，上面横七竖八地有着白色的痕迹。对哈罗德衣服的检查发现，一些裤兜里塞着七块女士手帕。这些发现促使人们对这栋房子进行更彻底的检查。检查厨房水槽下方时发现了一把带血的折叠刀。
Harold's father later claimed that the blood on the knife was his, as he had cut his finger slaughtering a chicken a week earlier. But this didn't explain a saucepan filled with bloody water that was found alongside the knife, or a blood-stained plank of wood discovered behind the kitchen coal burner. The rooms upstairs were re-examined. Scanning the ceiling in one of the bedrooms, a constable noticed what appeared to be blood smeared across a hatch that led to an attic. Realizing that Harold would have needed to stand on something to gain access to the attic
哈罗德的父亲后来声称刀上的血是他的，因为他在一周前宰鸡时割破了手指。但这并不能解释随刀一起发现的一锅装满血水的平底锅，也不能解释在厨房燃煤炉后面发现的一块带血的木板。楼上的房间被重新检查。一名警员扫描其中一间卧室的天花板时，注意到通往阁楼的舱口上似乎有血迹。意识到哈罗德需要踩在什么东西上才能进入阁楼
space, the constable searched his bedroom and found a small table with a cloth lying across it. He lifted the cloth, revealing a tabletop streaked with blood stains. Hoisting his upper body into the cramped attic hatch, the constable shone a torch into the darkness. Lying spread out on top of the beams was the partially clothed body of Florence Little lying in a pool of blood. The constable carefully removed the deceased 11-year-old from the attic, handing her tiny
空间，这名警员搜查了他的卧室，发现了一张铺着桌布的小桌子。他掀开桌布，露出一张布满血迹的桌面。这名警员将上半身探进狭窄的阁楼舱口，用手电筒照进黑暗中。弗洛伦斯·利特尔半裸的尸体呈大字形躺在横梁顶部的一个血泊中。这名警员小心翼翼地将这位已故的11岁女孩从阁楼上抬下来，把她娇小的
body to another officer below. Harold's father Philip watched on in disbelief. Then, he went to find his son. Harold Jones was chatting to a friend approximately 320 metres from his home when he saw his father approaching. As reported in the Manchester Guardian, Philip said to Harold, Sonny, come here. They have found that body in our house.
身体交给了下面另一名警员。哈罗德的父亲菲利普在一旁难以置信地看着。然后，他去找他的儿子。哈罗德·琼斯在距离他家大约320米的地方和一个朋友聊天时，看到他的父亲走了过来。据《曼彻斯特卫报》报道，菲利普对哈罗德说：“儿子，过来。他们在我们家里找到了那具尸体。”
Harold replied, I have never done it dad. Philip said in response, you or we will have the blame. Do come out and face it. Philip Jones then performed the citizen's arrest of his own son, escorting him home without resistance. As they walked down the street, Harold called over his shoulder to his friend. Goodbye, another holiday. When Harold walked through the front door, his mother told him, Be brave my son, they
哈罗德回答说：“我从来没干过，爸爸。”菲利普回应道：“你或我们都会受到责备。出来面对它吧。”随后菲利普·琼斯对自己的儿子实施了公民逮捕，在没有遭到反抗的情况下将他护送回家。当他们走在街上时，哈罗德向身后的朋友喊道：“再见，又是一个假期。”当哈罗德走进前门时，他的母亲告诉他：“勇敢点，我的儿子，他们
have found the body in the house. Florence died of blood loss caused by a slash to her throat, with almost all the blood in her body having drained away. An analysis of her stomach contents determined that Florence died between 9.30 and 10pm the previous night, coinciding with the exact time period that she was inside the Jones home, but before her mother stopped by looking for her. When Florence's mother, Elsie, heard of her daughter's murder, she collapsed and was bedridden for weeks.
在家里找到了尸体。”弗洛伦斯死于喉部被割伤导致的失血，她体内的血几乎已经流干。对她胃内容物的分析确定，弗洛伦斯在前一天晚上9点30分至10点之间死亡，这与她在琼斯家内部的准确时间吻合，但早于她的母亲过来寻找她的时间。当弗洛伦斯的母亲埃尔茜听到女儿被谋杀的消息时，她晕倒了，卧床数周。
Reports asserted that she remained in a state of unconsciousness for days on end. Crowds of curious onlookers gathered outside her home, wanting to know the status of the police investigation. A similar group also lingered outside the Jones residence. Schoolchildren even sold water to rubber-neckers. Harold Jones was formally placed under arrest by the local police. A doctor physically examined him and noticed slight abrasions to his left and right forearms and a scratch on his right wrist.
报道断言，她连续几天处于不省人事的状态。好奇的旁观者聚集在她家门外，想了解警方调查的进展。琼斯住宅外也逗留着类似的人群。甚至有学童向看热闹的人卖水。哈罗德·琼斯被当地警方正式逮捕。一名医生对他的身体进行了检查，发现他的左右前臂有轻微擦伤，右腕上有抓痕。
Harold maintained he had received the injuries from falling from a bicycle a few days earlier and said this was also the cause of blood stains found on a pair of his trousers. But the doctor was of the opinion that the wounds were fresh and nowhere near severe enough to cause the heavy stains found on Harold's pants. He put the abrasions down to Harold squeezing through the adicatch to hide Florence's body and his trousers were bloodied from carrying her body. In town, an angry mob of 500 locals descended on the Abitaliri police station, demanding Harold's immediate release.
哈罗德坚称这些伤是他几天前从自行车上摔下来造成的，并说这也是他的某条裤子上发现血迹的原因。但医生的意见是，这些伤口很新鲜，根本不足以造成哈罗德裤子上的重度污渍。他将这些擦伤归咎于哈罗德为了藏匿弗洛伦斯尸体而挤过阁楼舱口，而他的裤子沾满血迹是因为搬运了她的尸体。在镇上，500名愤怒的当地人涌向阿伯泰勒里警察局，要求立即释放哈罗德。
Their support for him was unwavering, despite the teen's implication in the murder of yet another young girl. Some were so convinced that he was being stitched up again that they threatened to kill the officers involved in his arrest. The station's superintendent was tasked with trying to calm the mob and told them, I have found the body of the child in the attic of Harold Jones, fairly murdered, and I have arrested Harold Jones. I think this is all I can tell you, and it would help us if you disperse and go to your
尽管这名少年卷入了又一起谋杀年轻女孩的案件，但他们对他的支持依然坚定不移。有些人坚信他又一次被陷害了，以至于他们威胁要杀死参与逮捕他的警官。该局的警长任务是试图安抚暴徒并告诉他们：“我在哈罗德·琼斯的阁楼里找到了这个惨遭杀害的孩子的尸体，并且我已经逮捕了哈罗德·琼斯。我想这就是我能告诉你们的全部，如果你们能散去并回到各自的
homes. Following the ordeal, the superintendent, likely overcome with stress, spent the rest of the weekend in bed on doctor's orders. A coroner's inquest began on July 11, three days after Florence was killed, to determine whether Harold Jones should once again stand trial for murder. Harold professed his innocence, just as he had done with the Frida Bernel case. Halfway through the inquest, he spotted his mother on the balcony and yelled out to her, Hello mum.
家里，这将对我们有所帮助。”事件发生后，警长可能因压力过大，遵医嘱在床上度过了整个周末。为了确定哈罗德·琼斯是否应该再次出庭接受谋杀审判，7月11日，即弗洛伦斯被杀三天后，死因研讯开始了。正如他对弗里达·伯内尔案所做的那样，哈罗德宣称自己无罪。研讯进行到一半时，他发现了阳台上的母亲，并向她大喊：“嗨，妈妈。”
She replied, Hello son, and was promptly removed from the courtroom to prevent further interruptions. As reported in the Manchester Guardian, Harold's sister Flossie had to be dragged in by her father to give evidence. She cried constantly, hardly able to speak of her close friend's murder. Harold did not even glance at her, instead staring straight ahead with an emotionless expression. The inquest was adjourned until July 23, at which time the coroner summed up his findings. He told the jury it was customary to look for some motive in such crimes, but this was
她回答说：“嗨，儿子”，并立即被请出法庭以防止进一步的干扰。据《曼彻斯特卫报》报道，哈罗德的妹妹弗洛西不得不被她的父亲拉进来作证。她一直在哭，几乎说不出她亲密朋友被谋杀的事。哈罗德甚至没有看她一眼，而是面无表情地直视前方。研讯休会至7月23日，届时验尸官总结了他的调查结果。他告诉陪审团，在这样的罪行中寻找某种动机是惯例，但这
a case in which there appeared to be no motive. He reminded them that although they might consider Harold Jones a madman, they had no jurisdiction to inquire into the mind of a person. All they need to do was determine whether he was guilty or not. The inquest jury deliberated for 30 minutes before finding Harold Jones guilty of the willful murder of Florence Little, meaning that he would face a criminal trial for her murder. He displayed no emotion upon hearing the verdict, and when asked if he had anything to say, he
是一个似乎没有动机的案件。他提醒他们，尽管他们可能认为哈罗德·琼斯是一个疯子，但他们无权调查一个人的思想。他们需要做的全部事情就是确定他是否有罪。研讯陪审团商议了30分钟，随后裁定哈罗德·琼斯蓄意谋杀弗洛伦斯·利特尔罪名成立，这意味着他将面临谋杀罪的刑事审判。听到裁决时他没有表现出任何情绪，当被问及是否有话要说时，他
jumped to his feet and loudly exclaimed, not guilty. Harold was sent back to prison to await trial. While awaiting trial for Florence Little's murder, Harold put pen to paper and wrote, I, Harold Jones, confess, I did willfully and deliberately murder Florence Little on July 8, causing her to die without preparation to meet her God, the reason for doing so being the desire to kill. His written confession went on to detail how he strangled her before cutting her throat and placing her head over the kitchen sink to drain her of blood.
一跃而起，大声喊道：“无罪。”哈罗德被送回监狱等待审判。在等待审判弗洛伦斯·利特尔谋杀案期间，哈罗德提起笔写道：“我，哈罗德·琼斯，供认，我确实在7月8日蓄意且故意谋杀了弗洛伦斯·利特尔，导致她在没有准备好面见上帝的情况下死亡，这样做的原因是对杀戮的渴望。”他的书面供词接着详细描述了他是如何勒死她，然后割断她的喉咙，并把她的头放在厨房水槽上放干血。
He then described how he hoisted her body into the attic using some rope and afterwards cleaned himself and the kitchen. As I was having a bath, Mrs Little came to the door, just as I was washing my head and my body. I denied Florence was in the house and went back and finished my bath. On November 1, 1921, Harold Jones appeared in court and pleaded guilty to the murder of Florence Little. His written confession was read aloud, before the director of public prosecutions made an
然后他描述了他是如何用一根绳子将她的尸体吊进阁楼，并在事后清理了自己和厨房。“当我正在洗澡时，利特尔太太来到了门前，正当我在洗头洗澡的时候。我否认弗洛伦斯在屋里，然后回去洗完了澡。”1921年11月1日，哈罗德·琼斯出庭，对谋杀弗洛伦斯·利特尔的指控表示认罪。宣读了他的书面供词后，公共检察署署长作出了
announcement. The statement was to be read to the court, in order to put to rest any worry remaining amongst the families of Abitaliri. This one began, I, Harold Jones, willfully and deliberately murdered Frida Bernel in Mr Mortimer's warehouse on the 5th of February. Harold later explained that Frida had not left Mortimer's store to check with her father about buying the chicken grit. Rather, Harold had told her to accompany him to Mortimer's shed, where he had the supplies
一则宣布。该声明将在法庭上宣读，以平息阿伯泰勒里各家庭中残留的任何担忧。这一篇开头写道：“我，哈罗德·琼斯，于2月5日在莫蒂默先生的仓库里蓄意且故意谋杀了弗里达·伯内尔。”哈罗德后来解释说，弗里达并没有离开莫蒂默的店去跟她父亲核实购买鸡砂砾的事。相反，哈罗德告诉她陪他去莫蒂默的棚屋，那里有她需要的物资。
she required. To avoid them being seen together, he told her to walk on her head and that he would catch up with her. After he strangled and sexually assaulted Frida, Harold left her body in a sack in the shed. He then returned to Mortimer's to continue his shift. At around 10am, Harold was tasked to run an errand to the shed to gather some potatoes and deliver them to a nearby address.
为了避免他们被看到在一起，他告诉她闭着眼睛走，他会赶上她的。在他勒死并性侵弗里达后，哈罗德将她的尸体留在棚屋的一个麻袋里。然后他回到莫蒂默继续他的轮班。大约上午10点，哈罗德的任务是跑腿去棚屋拿一些土豆并将它们送到附近的地址。
He was accompanied by 10-year-old Francis Mortimer, who provided a statement that contradicted his father's and instead highlighted Harold as a suspect. Usually, Francis would wheel a trolley into the shed to help Harold load the goods, but on this occasion, Harold told Francis that the trolley was unnecessary and had him wait outside. Harold then opened the shed's door just a fraction before shimmying his way in. Francis assumed there was something on the other side preventing the door from being opened fully.
陪同他的是10岁的弗朗西斯·莫蒂默，他提供的陈述与其父亲的矛盾，反而将哈罗德凸显为嫌疑人。通常，弗朗西斯会推着手推车进棚屋帮哈罗德装卸货物，但这一次，哈罗德告诉弗朗西斯手推车是不需要的，并让他等在外面。然后，哈罗德将棚屋的门开了一条缝，随后侧身挤了进去。弗朗西斯以为门后有什么东西挡住，导致门无法完全打开。
Harold emerged a short while later with a sack of potatoes and told Francis to deliver them to a nearby address, adding that he would soon follow. He eventually caught up with Francis and they delivered the stock before returning to the store. After that night, as the search for Frida was well underway, Harold returned to the shed with Francis and another local teen. Francis explained that it was about 10-20pm when the group headed down the dark, quiet laneway.
不久后，哈罗德拿着一袋土豆出来了，并告诉弗朗西斯把它们送到附近的地址，并补充说他很快就会跟上。他最终追上了弗朗西斯，他们运送了货物，然后返回店里。那天晚上之后，在寻找弗里达的行动全面展开时，哈罗德和弗朗西斯以及另一个当地少年回到了棚屋。弗朗西斯解释说，那群人沿着黑暗、安静的小巷走时大约是10点20分。
When they were halfway there, Harold turned to his two companions and said, You wait here while I go down to the shed. He then walked on alone. At one point, he turned back to the others and whispered loudly, You like keep quiet, before entering the shed. When Harold exited, he locked the door behind him and approached Francis and the other teen, again whispering for them to keep quiet. Harold said he came up with the lie that he had left the shed door unlocked, thereby making
当他们走到半路时，哈罗德转过身对他的两个同伴说：“你们在这里等我，我到棚屋去。”然后他独自一人走了。有一次，他转过身对着其他人大声耳语：“你们最好保持安静”，然后走进了棚屋。当哈罗德出来时，他在身后锁上了门，走近弗朗西斯和另一个少年，再次耳语让他们保持安静。哈罗德说，他编造了自己把棚屋门没锁的谎言，从而
it plausible that someone else could have killed Frida in there. He claimed to know about creating alibis and covering his tracks from reading countless detective novels. Then alone, Harold returned to the shed and removed the sack that held Frida, remarking that she was so light he could carry her body under one arm. He then dumped her in the alleyway, where she remained undiscovered until the next morning. It was believed that Harold killed Florence Little because he enjoyed the publicity and celebrity status he received after murdering Frida Bernal.
使别人可能在那里杀死弗里达变得貌似合理。他声称自己从阅读无数的侦探小说中知道了如何制造不在场证明和掩盖行踪。然后哈罗德独自一人回到棚屋，搬走了装着弗里达的麻袋，评论说她太轻了，他可以把她的尸体夹在一个胳膊底下。然后他把她扔进了小巷里，直到第二天早上才被发现。人们认为哈罗德杀害弗洛伦斯·利特尔是因为他喜欢谋杀弗里达·伯内尔后获得的宣传和名人地位。
Harold could offer no explanation for the murder, other than stating he had been commanded to kill following a blinding crash that turned everything crimson. He said he could not disobey the commands of a demon in his head. The judge was satisfied that although Harold Jones was not normal, he was sane enough to understand that he had confessed to his crimes. He addressed Harold, passing the sentence that he be detained at his majesty's pleasure, meaning that he would be imprisoned for an indeterminate period. The judge asked that nobody make a spectacle outside court as it was clear that Harold
对于这起谋杀案，哈罗德无法给出任何解释，只是说在一场耀眼的撞击把一切变成血红之后，他受到了杀人的命令。他说他无法违抗脑海中恶魔的命令。法官认为，尽管哈罗德·琼斯并不正常，但他的理智足以理解他已经承认了自己的罪行。他向哈罗德发表讲话，判处他听候国王陛下发落，这意味着他将被无限期监禁。法官要求任何人不要在法庭外大惊小怪，因为很显然哈罗德
was vain and loved being in the public eye. During this, Harold Jones was escorted out without incident. Those who wondered why Harold Jones had pleaded guilty before his trial even began soon had an answer. At 15 years old, Harold was beneath the legal age to receive capital punishment as a sentence. If the trial extended beyond his 16th birthday on January 11, 1922, a guilty verdict would result in Harold facing the death penalty. By pleading guilty to both murders before he turned 16, Harold Jones saved himself from
爱慕虚荣，喜欢成为公众瞩目的焦点。在此期间，哈罗德·琼斯被顺利带离。那些想知道为什么哈罗德·琼斯在审判开始前就认罪的人很快就得到了答案。在15岁时，哈罗德未达到判处死刑的法定年龄。如果审判延期到他1922年1月16日的16岁生日之后，有罪判决将导致哈罗德面临死刑。通过在16岁之前对两起谋杀案认罪，哈罗德·琼斯避免了
the hangman's noose. They appeared to show no remorse for his actions and was labelled a calculating psychopath. The residents of Abitaliri struggled to come to terms with the realization that a popular local teenager, whose innocence they had believed in, was in fact a cult-blooded killer. In the aftermath of the confession, Herbert Mortimer admitted that the alibi he'd provided for Harold following Frida Bernel's murder was false. He had said that Harold was at his shop at the time of the attack, only later confessing that he had made this up because he was certain Harold was not a murderer.
走上绞刑架。他似乎对自己的行为没有表现出一丝悔意，并被贴上了精于算计的精神病态者的标签。阿比塔利里的居民们很难接受这样一个现实：一个他们曾坚信其纯洁无辜的本地受欢迎少年，实际上是一个冷血杀手。在供认之后，赫伯特·莫蒂默承认他为哈罗德在弗里达·伯内尔谋杀案后提供的不在场证明是假的。他曾说哈罗德在袭击发生时在他的店铺里，直到后来才承认他是捏造的，因为他确信哈罗德不是凶手。
Following this revelation, the Mortimer's became outcasts and were forced to close their shop and leave town. Harold's family remained in Abitaliri, his parents staying in their house until their deaths. Harold Jones was shuffled between various prisons throughout the United Kingdom. He became known as a model inmate who had a cheery personality and liked competing in prison sports. He was well liked by both fellow prisoners and guards and was known to gloat about fooling
这一揭露之后，莫蒂默一家成了社会弃儿，被迫关掉店铺离开小镇。哈罗德的家人留在了阿比塔利里，他的父母一直住在他们的房子里直到去世。哈罗德·琼斯在英国的各个监狱之间被不断转押。他被称为模范犯人，性格开朗，喜欢参加监狱体育活动。他深受同狱犯人和狱警的喜爱，并且因吹嘘自己愚弄了
Scotland Yard detectives with his cunning. Despite a psychiatrist recommending that Harold remain in prison forever, he was released on parole at age 35 after serving 20 years. According to the book A Desire to Kill, The Mystery of Harold Jones by Kevin Banks, police commissioner and prison reformer Alexander Patterson approved his release, saying, One day he will be the father of happy children. This sentiment was echoed by a prison chaplain who wrote of Harold in 1933. He is a very nice lad who was a foolish boy.
苏格兰场的侦探而足智多谋而闻名。尽管一名精神病医生建议将哈罗德永远关在监狱里，但在服刑20年后，他在35岁时被假释出狱。根据凯文·班克斯所著的书《杀戮的渴望：哈罗德·琼斯之谜》，警察局长兼监狱改革家亚历山大·帕特森批准了他的假释，并说道：“总有一天他会成为快乐孩子的父亲。”1933年，一位监狱牧师在谈到哈罗德时也呼应了这种看法。他是一个非常好的小伙子，以前只是个糊涂的孩子。
He puts his crime down to reading too many thrillers. I think he will be a much more useful person outside prison than inside. Following Harold's release, his immediate whereabouts were unclear. As he was granted parole at the height of World War II, some sources claim he was subscripted into the Royal Artillery as a gunfitter or served in the Merchant Navy. He adopted his mother's maiden name, going by Harry Stevens. In 1948, Harold married a 36 year old woman named Muriel. They lived together with Muriel's elderly father, a former police officer, in the London
他把自己的罪行归咎于读了太多惊悚小说。我认为他在监狱外面会比在监狱里面更有用。哈罗德获释后，他的去向一度不明。由于他是在第二次世界大战最激烈的时候获得假释的，一些消息来源称他被征召入皇家炮兵担任炮兵修理工或在商船队服役。他采用了他母亲的婚前姓氏，化名为哈里·史蒂文斯。1948年，哈罗德与一个名叫穆里尔的36岁女子结婚。他们和穆里尔的老父亲（一名退休警察）一起住在伦敦
neighbourhood of Fulham. It is not clear whether Muriel or her father knew of his criminal past. In 1950, Muriel gave birth to a baby girl, the couple's only child. Harold is reported as having held jobs as a sheet metal worker, caretaker and a night watchman. He died of bone cancer in 1971, aged 64. Shortly before his death, he asked Muriel to ensure his real name, Harold Jones, appeared on his death certificate.
富勒姆社区。目前还不清楚穆里尔或她的父亲是否知道他的犯罪过去。1950年，穆里尔生下了一个女婴，这是两人的独生女。据报道，哈罗德曾担任过钣金工、看门人和夜间保安。他于1971年因骨癌去世，享年64岁。在他去世前不久，他要求穆里尔确保他的真实姓名哈罗德·琼斯出现在他的死亡证明上。
Following his release in 1941, Harold Jones appeared to live a normal, law-abiding life. However, crime historians and members of law enforcement have recently speculated that Harold may have been responsible for a number of vicious, unsolved murders in London during the 1950s and 60s. These were termed the Hammersmith Nude Murders, and the perpetrator was dubbed Jack the Stripper. He was given this name because his crimes bore striking similarities to those of Jack the Ripper, who stalked and murdered sex workers throughout London nearly a century earlier.
1941年获释后，哈罗德·琼斯似乎过着正常、遵纪守法的生活。然而，犯罪历史学家和执法人员最近推测，哈罗德可能应对20世纪50年代和60年代伦敦发生的一系列恶性、未破的谋杀案负责。这些案件被称为“哈默史密斯裸体谋杀案”，凶手被冠以“开膛手杰克”的称号。他被赋予这个名字是因为他的罪行与大约一个世纪前在伦敦各处追踪并杀害性工作者的开膛手杰克惊人地相似。
Jack the Stripper had six confirmed victims, but it's likely that up to eight women fell victim to the unknown assailant. His targets were sex workers, whose bodies were all found in a state of undress. The most common cause of death was strangulation, with the victims' bodies showing no signs of a struggle prior to their murders. In most cases, the women's teeth or dentures were taken. Jack the Stripper would dump their bodies with seemingly reckless abandon, but left behind little evidence.
“开膛手杰克”有六名确定的受害者，但可能有高达八名女性沦为这位未知袭击者的受害者。他的目标是性工作者，她们的尸体被发现时都处于衣衫不整的状态。最常见的死因是勒死，受害者的尸体在遇害前没有显示出任何挣扎的迹象。在大多数情况下，女性的牙齿或假牙被拿走了。开膛手杰克丢弃她们尸体时显得毫无顾忌，但留下的证据却很少。
Despite an extensive and thorough investigation by Scotland Yard, the killer was never apprehended. When specs of paint were found on the bodies of three victims, investigators wondered whether the killer worked in the auto repair industry, but this lead went nowhere. At the time, Scotland Yard was unaware that Harold Jones, now going by the name Harry Stevens, was living very nearby. In fact, his home was within a four-street radius from where two of the victims resided. He also worked in the sheet metal industry and had access to an industrial area where some of the bodies were found.
尽管苏格兰场进行了广泛而彻底的调查，但凶手始终未被抓获。当在三名受害者的尸体上发现油漆微粒时，调查人员怀疑凶手是否在汽车修理行业工作，但这条线索最终无果而终。当时，苏格兰场并不知道现在化名为哈里·史蒂文斯的哈罗德·琼斯住在非常近的地方。事实上，他的家就在其中两名受害者居住地四条街的半径范围内。他还在钣金行业工作过，并且能够进入发现部分尸体的工业区。
The murders abruptly stopped in 1965 on Harold Jones' 59th birthday. Some have speculated that perhaps he was no longer able to kill due to suffering from the cancer that would eventually kill him. Attorney author Neil Milkins is certain that Harold Jones was Jack the Stripper, as is David Wilson, a professor of criminology at Birmingham City University. In 2019, the BBC aired a documentary titled Dark Sun, the Hunt for a Serial Killer, detailing Harold's possible connections to the Hammersmith nude murders. The producers also tracked down his daughter, who had no idea about her father's criminal
谋杀案在1965年哈罗德·琼斯的59岁生日时戛然而止。一些人推测，也许由于饱受最终夺去他生命的癌症折磨，他再也无法杀人了。律师兼作家尼尔·米尔金斯确信哈罗德·琼斯就是开膛手杰克，伯明翰城市大学的犯罪学教授大卫·威尔逊也这么认为。2019年，BBC播出了名为《黑暗之日：搜寻连环杀手》的纪录片，详细讲述了哈罗德与哈默史密斯裸体谋杀案的可能联系。制片人们还找到了他的女儿，她对父亲的犯罪过去
past. Harold was known to leave his family on occasion, choosing to board in a hostel for days at a time, though he only ever did this on weekdays. Coincidentally, all Jack the Stripper murders were committed on weekdays. In his book A Desire to Kill, The Mystery of Harold Jones, author Kevin Banks points to the women's handkerchiefs that 15-year-old Harold kept in his possession. Banks likens this collection to the teeth and dentures stolen from the Hammersmith victims. He also argues that the Hammersmith victims, who were all small and petite, had similar
一无所知。众所周知，哈罗德有时会离开家人，选择在旅社里住上几天，尽管他只在工作日这样做。巧合的是，“开膛手杰克”的所有谋杀案都是在工作日犯下的。作家凯文·班克斯在其著作《杀戮的渴望：哈罗德·琼斯之谜》中指出，15岁的哈罗德曾将女性手帕据为己有。班克斯将这一收藏比作从哈默史密斯受害者身上偷来的牙齿和假牙。他还辩称，哈默史密斯受害者身材都娇小，与
builds to Frida Bernal and Florence Little. But, without any forensic evidence from the crimes, it's unlikely that the killer's identity will ever be known. Harold Jones continued to terrorise the people of Abitolleri even after his release from prison. When organ music was heard emanating from the front room of the Jones family home, rumours circulated that he was back in town. In 1950, he was spotted visiting the graves of Frida Bernal and Florence Little.
弗里达·伯内尔和弗洛伦斯·利特尔有着相似的身材。但是，由于没有来自犯罪现场的任何法医证据，凶手的身份恐怕永远不会为人所知。哈罗德·琼斯出狱后，依然继续恐吓着阿比托莱里的居民。当琼斯家族住宅的前厅传出管风琴音乐时，谣言四起，说他又回到了镇上。1950年，人们看到他去拜访弗里达·伯内尔和弗洛伦斯·利特尔的墓地。
He was also known to pop into the local fish and chip shop on occasion. Abitolleri author Kevin Banks said that when he was little and misbehaved, his nan would tell him to watch out or, Harold Jones will get you. Despite the passage of a century, Frida and Florence's murders have not left the minds of Abitolleri residents. In 2018, local author Neil Milkins raised £4,000 to have the girls' headstones restored after years of neglect had caused them to fall into disrepair. Hundreds of people attended the unveiling of the repaired graves, including relatives
人们还知道他偶尔会去当地的鱼薯店坐坐。阿比托莱里的作家凯文·班克斯说，他小时候如果不听话，他的奶奶就会叫他小心点，“否则哈罗德·琼斯会抓走你”。尽管一个世纪过去了，弗里达和弗洛伦斯的谋杀案并没有从阿比托莱里居民的脑海中淡去。2018年，当地作家尼尔·米尔金斯筹集了4000英镑，用于修复女孩们的墓碑，此前多年的疏于照料导致墓碑年久失修。数百人参加了修复墓碑的揭幕仪式，其中包括
of Frida and Florence. Florence's niece told the South Wales Argus newspaper, It is truly wonderful what happened here today. The new grave means my aunt can finally be at peace. Another relative added, It is very emotional being here, but I think they will both be happy with their new graves. God bless them. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
弗里达和弗洛伦斯的亲属。弗洛伦斯的侄女对《南威尔士阿格us报》说：“今天这里发生的事真是太棒了。新墓地意味着我的姑妈终于可以安息了。”另一位亲属补充说：“来到这里百感交集，但我认为她们都会对自己的新墓地感到高兴。愿上帝保佑她们。”本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。